I wanted to do a
lady's country or a question,
and I loved the story at work because it helps
my family with work,
because what was in it
[Music] was the
reason or motivation for the number of his love and feeling for
Freemasonry, that he would be standing next to me, meaning
after the operation
[Music]
Whoever saw it, take them instead.  And he brings them
to the world, to
tourism, to
foreigners, to the French, to the Germans, and he takes them with a twist
and twists them
first, to the sun, because it is beautiful. To the horoscope, I mean, he
acquired it from his love of questioning and knowledge,
Glory be to God, destiny. I mean, it was opened to the field,
and it was his job with love
[music].